مدينه جده اليوم وجماهير نادي الاتحاد على
موعد مع حفل استقبال اللاعب الفرنسي كريم
بنزيما لاعب نادي الاتحاد الجديد واللي
كان النادي اعلن عن انضمامه لصفوفه بعقد
لمده ثلاثه مواسم واليوم راح يكون في حفل
لاستقباله في ملعب الجوهره امس بنزيما وصل
الى جده وحقيقه الصور وفيديوهات وصوله
واستقباله ماليه المنصات وبالورود الصفراء
وبالشال الاصفر اللي وضعه بنزيما على
اكتافه وابتسامته اللي ما فارقت وجهه هذه
كانت اولى لحظاته في جده
[موسيقى]
ومثل ما قلت لكم حفله لاستقبال راح يكون
اليوم في ملعب الجوهر اللي بيتسع ل65 الف
مشجع وراح يبدا الحفل في الساعه تسعه الا
ربع مساء بتوقيت السعوديه وتمطر حتى تذاكر
عبر الموقع الرسمي لنادي الاتحاد وخلال
اول نصف ساعه اكثر من 30 الف تذكره ومن
دقائق اعلى النادي الاتحاد نفاذ تذاكر
الحفل وانه ما في بيع في الملعب وبنزيما
احتفل بالموضوع مع النادي وعمل ريتويت
للتغريده ومع الحديث عن حجم حفل الاستقبال
بنزيما وتقديمه لجمهور الاتحاد والاقبال
الهائل على حضور الحفل تساءل ناس لو هذه
راح تكون اكبر حفل استقبال للاعب كره قدم
في التاريخ من بحثنا توصلنا لانه يبدو
بنزيما راح ينافس بقوه في هذه القائمه
واحتمال كبير يقتحم القائمه في المركز
الثاني ويزيح مارادونا اللي كان استقبله
في نابولي في ايطاليا خصم 65 الف مشجع
خلينا
نلقي نظره على اكبر حفلات استقبال صارت
للاعبي كره قدم في العالم
[موسيقى]